next week for the fifth year in a row
we're taking our show down to San Diego
for Comic Life that's right we're gonna
be airing a week of shows live from the
historic Spreckels theater and this is
pretty cool the company that makes pop
vinyl figures Funko has once again
created four new limited edition Conan
pop figures
yeah
these are these are collectible vinyl
figures that we give out exclusively to
our audiences in San Diego we give these
figures out every year Funko has created
four new ones and here they are right
here and yes there are plastic dolls
anyway I don't know what else you want
me to say
usually the merchants eyes like this a
celebrity can do certain things to
increase the items value there are
certain things that a celebrity can do
if you're auctioning something off
you're giving away something to create
more value they might sign it they might
take a picture with it this year I went
the extra mile no one's ever done this
before
I took the time to get legally married
to every single one of this every single
one every single one I'm talking about
every single one we're going to give
away thousands and thousands of I
married each and every one of these
limited edition vinyl figurines it took
days to get through all of them for real
we actually taped it check it out do
Conan O'Brien take this Funko pop figure
to be your wife yes I do and this one I
do into this one yes and this one yes I
do
all D Wed yay I'm a bigamist
[Music]
I had sex with dolls
that's my new catchphrase I had sex with
dolls you know that the worst part isn't
that you had sex with dolls is that the
dolls are all you we're gonna be giving
away a ton of Conan pop figures during
our week at Comic Con so look for
details on you can get one at
instagram.com slash Conan Kahn Wednesday
July 17th through Saturday July 20th
[Applause]